[Music]
hey guys hey hi what's happening
um look at that look at tara and kai
now see now we finally got a show
now look at something that matters
we made it uh yeah how are you guys
we're great yeah we had a riverbend this
weekend and forecastle the weekend
before and it's it's been really awesome
i can't believe it that's uh tara you
have a grown adult female next to you
how is that possible
i know i know we've been raising her
right though so we're ready
i mean when were we at music midtown
what were you were you nine
ten how old are you
she did our first first sunday at
10 and then this will be our fourth year
so
wow we're here uh and and still has seen
more shows than brian stone
yeah i'm keeping the list
yeah
you know
just like his radio career his
microphone doesn't work you can't see
him
nothing about this makes it what is
wrong with you you're literally sitting
in front of a microphone and it doesn't
work you just told me it's a prop it's
it's a prop it's not really there
you can't hear me you can't i can't
understand what he's saying thank god
for the cat right guy at least there's
something interesting on that screen
yeah can we talk to the cat instead
yeah the guy yeah make some
introductions who all's here and then we
got daniel and then we got to daniel
what's up from the real rew bus what's
happening buddy i'm good uh charlotte
might drop in in a minute she just got
back to the house a minute ago
everything is happening we're trying to
get ready and chill at the same time
this week are you are you packed are you
in are you ready to go is the bus going
does it messed up
pretty much yeah i was just telling them
before you jumped on i'm very thankful
that we filled it up last year and
haven't driven it much since then when
uh diesel was about uh 350. it's a
little over five dollars now so uh saves
wait are you telling me that you've
still got the same gas in it that you
started with last year
pretty much i mean yeah we topped it off
on the way back from lindsay's mindaroo
farm and then uh just kind of drove just
a couple places around town here so i
haven't been far away since then i need
to consult with my car guy mr lord rust
taco uh is that okay can you keep gas on
a car for that long well he doesn't use
gas he uses diesel
well what
when
[Music]
it's making a strange noise when i turn
right
um you know you kind of have to learn a
lot of this you can add additives to uh
stabilize the fuel if you're going to
keep it in there term yeah
that's what we need eight eight and
eight monroe this is a slop and shot
what do you want to do
[Laughter]
what happened when did we get high
sorry i'm making i'm going around the
room barry i'm seeing how everybody's
life is i'm worried about his safety oh
we got it
brian stone was so mad about the car
talk he hung up
honestly it's better that way it's
better that way without right yeah yeah
move if that's what it took if that's
what it took good move
uh barry how are you
i'm good i put the shirt on for you my
name
just
and you know i don't know if you noticed
but i've been listening to my morning
jacket all day since we
since we posted our show or i've
listened to it
i'm getting pretty doggone excited i got
a note from tara today which is why tara
and kai are on they're going to be at
camp nut butter they got their
yeah they got their
their bat or their whatever you call
them
passes or whatever so they're coming now
i'm excited i'm getting all excited
about it again
now daniel where are you camping where's
your do you know your pod yet is is that
still the day of thing i forget how they
do it out there we will be at the group
plaza so we're going to be next to the
that's right new tent that they have
over there bonner has been very kind to
let us use their facilities to host flip
turn and some of the other crazy stuff
that we're doing
hey so you you tweeted a picture that i
saw today about uh the
the site right the picture of the site
then there's a couple of things that we
noticed about this does anything stick
out to you
yeah someone posted that on reddit uh
yesterday i believe i don't know where
in the heck they got it but it was clear
that it was taken in the past couple of
days because that road that comes from
bushy branch up to the main entrance
next to the arch or whatever was paved
and they only did that a month or two
ago uh there's a couple of things um
that's a fruit but stop and stop you
right there that's the first thing barry
and i noticed yeah
there's a person there is a paved road
right through center room comes such a
long way right
yeah i mean did you did you notice that
ross did you see the paved road that
comes right down through right past the
ferris wheel all the way down to the
what state or what to the witch stage
yeah but i'm so unfamiliar with the
layout that i wouldn't even know you
know what i'm looking at
but yeah and you don't remember half of
it very you know you being the uh paving
expert that you are did it look like the
paved road ended like halfway through
and turned back into dirt
that's what i couldn't tell it just it
looked uh it looked like it went between
what i would consider cenaru in the main
stage the west stage area
it's the dirt room it's the dirt road
you walk right up to uh that tent
yeah that comes out of media and all
that where we usually come out so
yeah which is the one that normally
would get wet
and muddy
and have puddles that's right so i was
not unhappy about it all right all right
what else did you notice on the picture
daniel
sorry i had to hit the mute button
because i was over in another tab
looking at it a couple of things they
put out what looks to be a couple of new
things out in the campgrounds i noticed
some tents kind of near our area that i
don't remember from last time
i'm sure you noticed this too brad they
moved the um the wall the hill the hill
i know it i know it they did it again
but it definitely looks like they moved
the wall in charlotte thinks that they
did move the hill we went over there
last summer to see the abbott brothers
and she looked at that and she was like
you know it does look different i know i
know hey this is my suggestion get
enough mushrooms in everybody that
hill's gonna start moving all day that
thing's gonna just keep moving
up down around
um
so i noticed the uh the walls too did
you do any sort of side by side
from an aerial photo from years past
because that seems like something you
would do i did one of those a couple of
years ago just to disprove you about the
hill i thought anyways but well let's do
that again so uh you know in this
another topic no i'd like to see what it
looks like with these walls because i'm
not gonna lie
barry we've talked about this before
during the lcd pearl jam year you know
the greatest year of brian stone's
existence
they we literally walked in and we said
these walls are in closer
yeah for sure
and we're convinced that they're gonna
do it again this year with 25 000
tickets sold yeah they're gonna have to
it it definitely is in closer
which is you know that's what you do you
make it comfortable
right i suggest piping drape i suggested
some paper tray pop
uh tara you can uh you got a pipe and
drape guy
oh yeah i got a couple
of this
uh speaking of uh large pipes hey brian
you excited
does my microphone work first of all no
of course it doesn't
but we can hear you we can hear you
i can hear you online
microphone not work yet you can hear me
that doesn't make sense to me so you
can't hear me
i mean i can't hear you but you're
sitting in front of a microphone that is
obviously not no
this is a prop i don't have a microphone
you sound like you're in a storm drain
making a prop brian stone
[Laughter]
i'm fine i'm good
[Applause]
why do you like you you literally have
not been on radio for this long you're
just playing radio in your basement
is that what you're doing
i'm so happy to see you
i got all right i i brian what are you
excited about we're going to be there
next week
before you get there just so you know
how brian is brian is the queen like he
is the episode of seinfeld where george
has the jerk store brian is the ultimate
jerk store guy whereas he will listen
and take every piece of abuse he'll ever
throw at him and then as he's driving
home
damn it that's a great line when it was
really the worst line you've ever heard
in your life he is the walking talking
jerk store it is it's true
it's very true actually
yeah that's very scary you know i need a
few minutes all right i know
you know what i i i do want to say brian
is probably the only i know he is he's
the only one in this group who's been to
every single one right it's true well i
i know i have been to every one of them
yeah
the first year i just was there i jumped
the fence on saturday and hung out for
the night so i didn't camp i didn't i
didn't know what i was doing i just
heard of this thing jam band music was
just becoming a thing to me at that time
and uh but ever since then i've been
there all weekend every year
sitting in your car listening to the
shins is not going to bother me that was
one year
[Laughter]
it was an entire year it was literally
an entire festival
i was really into the shenzhen
do you remember when brian sat in this
car all day listening to this shin show
and then he went to the shin show and he
came back do you remember what he said
no please remind me that [ __ ] sucked i'm
never going back
what are you excited about this year
uh
really only two that are just absolute
pretty pretty excited about the war on
drugs uh i was really hoping to get them
on the what stage early i wanted that
sound so bad
uh just have to deal with the witch on
saturday afternoon and then i've skipped
the opportunity to see tool
three four or five times in my life and
so this will be the time i make sure to
knock that out
remind me when when and where
so it's on which where's war on drugs
what time uh 7 45 saturday on the witch
that's going to be right that's going to
be a mess and absolutely even if you're
even with a small crowd that's going to
be a mess
yeah i think that your inclination of
like six o'clock 6 30 on the what that
was really sort of ideal for them that
had been beautiful remember we were
talking we were talking about this last
week barry and daniel's felt it a
million times there's just a moment
there on friday and you hope it's early
on saturday but you really you hope it's
on friday where the right band's on the
what and then the sun's going down and
then the soundscape just becomes the it
just becomes bonnaroo it is literally
the sound of the entire festival and war
on drugs would have been at friday
evening six o'clock would have been
would have been fantastic um and then
just a bunch of other stuff that just
got little minor highlights you know
i'll go see robert plant and allison
krause because it's on the what stage
and that'll be that'll sound and be fun
sound good lord haron everybody loves
that band i guess i need to see what the
fuss is all about
and then how about this just for the for
the what stage on
saturday
21 savage then billy strings then tool
seen they could see a lineup like that
anywhere in the world
so i thought that was interesting okay
okay okay i know you're doing here i
know what you're doing you're trying to
pretend that you know anything about 21
savage and you're acting as if oh isn't
this weird guys tell me something about
21 7.
stop it right now you know what i know
21 savage doesn't sound like three
strings and pool
[Laughter]
how do you know if it's not you could it
could be country how do you know i know
enough to know it's not country stop
right
on your on your schedule brian
how many are actually circled as in
don't miss there's a there's jeff moore
on drugs
yeah that's why they're 90 acts you're
going to see two
that depends on the weather it depends
on the weather
let me let me just be honest with you if
you're listening to this and you have
blue hair
run
all right
uh
on the what stage on sunday afternoon if
i'm around that'll be fun
i don't have to see it but that'll be
fun
um
[Music]
jewett and the lions on saturday
the fact that you
brian i know you the fact that i do this
to him every year so
there is always a band that i tell you
you have to see and when have i ever
been wrong to you
you've never been wrong so give me one
this year
i cannot believe you are pulling a
proper poo poo
on nathaniel rate lift you will
adore
he's more in your lane than any other
band that's playing that weekend oh
that's not entirely true but it's uh no
i've seen with daniel ray lip i know
what he i know all about it's just it's
not it's not musty stuff on a sunday
afternoon i don't know that i'll be
there on sunday afternoon
you always make it to the end of sunday
usually but
i'm worried about this year this is my
life and death at monroe this year i
don't i'm afraid that my baby's gone i'm
afraid i'm going to walk away very
disappointed i hate to say that you know
russ
russ what did we say about brian last
week when we were trying to explain who
brian was
oh he loves he hates uh sunshine hates
kittens
there's a cat right there he hates that
cat he's literally looking at your cat
daniel's saying yeah stupid cat why does
it breathe don't hate on even
there's so many things that i like a lot
this will be the longest show in the
world what is it kind of do
i said beer and blue haired girls
by the way to brian's credit the last
time i ever saw kai and brian together
she was putting ribbons in his hair so i
give brian props for that facials yeah
yeah we were doing a podcast as well so
that's right so good for brian for that
i'm a street player man i'm a team
player but i'm a team player
uh daniel what are your uh we went
through our camp misses last week we i
didn't do a damn thing what are what are
yours tan impala in the car you
listening to a tampon on the bus over
and over close king gizzard and the
lizard wizard
yeah it's a good one i can't believe
that's not on yours brian what's
what in the world is wrong with you i
don't i'm not familiar i've only heard
the name it's such a weird band name i
was like who the hell would that could
that possibly be
they probably suck
[Laughter]
yeah there's this whole sub genre that
i've fallen in love with the past couple
of years that isn't just damon paul it's
like a lot of australian psych rock
bands so it's same it's king gizzard
it's pond a lot of others another one
that got introduced to me back at
okeechobee was ocean alley um all those
are right up my alley i haven't seen
team gizzard live before it's right up
your ocean alley get it and i totally
get that okay well that's that's right
oh that's late 11 30 at night
i'm getting old i don't know if i can
pull that off
[Laughter]
11 30.
you got plans what are you going to be
11 years old
i'm not going to be asleep i'm going to
be drunk or i'm going to be you know
lost somewhere
i don't know i made a mark right there
okay
you and the other papa smurf are going
to be chasing blue hairs right now so i
i get it
you never know don't make don't make any
hit rock solid plans because it's not
going to come go through most of the
time
well there that's exactly right all
right so it's it's king gizzard who else
you got
i'm kind of bummed out that they uh
scheduled keem gizzard right at the same
time as disclosure because that was
going to be number one and two for me so
at best i can bolt it from king gizzard
and see like 10 minutes of disclosure
but i'm really looking forward to flume
a lot of our campus looking forward to
that
um honestly this boundary i'm purposely
not trying to like over schedule myself
i'm just going to be there to choose oh
boy that's a tough tough ask
don't over sketch yourself with this
bottle but the other big have to for me
is goth babe on thursday night i have
absolutely fallen in love with that band
i saw him at okeechobee blew me away i
can't wait to see him at rue because um
they're originally from tennessee so you
know this is going to be a big deal for
them
that's what taco's dreaming of is a goth
babe
was she did you have
uh i don't so i i hear you on um
especially on king gizzard and i think
that we mentioned it last week barry
about the the one
it feels like the biggest conflict would
be disclosure and
and uh king gizzard right
yeah yeah daniel mentioned it yeah i
think that's it for
for a lot of us anyway we'll manage tara
i keep seeing kai's head and i can't
wait to hear yeah we'll get to that i'm
sure
but actually keep seeing the
yeah i don't even playing i don't even
know let's go
had
that's the best attitude that you can
have for bonnaroo uh i don't know who's
gonna be there let's just go
for me it's like 60 40. it's like we're
there for the music but we're there for
the people and we're there to have a
good weekend and catch what we catch and
um
kai will drag me around to see new bands
that i don't know about so i'm excited
for that
and other than that i'm just excited to
to be in it so barry i think that i mean
you're you're way up there in the
hierarchy of camp but when it comes to
um my soul sister when it comes to
decorating and making camp goofy there's
nobody that even comes close to tara
she that's right she's the only one
that's going to keep camp nut butter
alive this year she's that
where yeah you know it's not going to be
me or russ we're going to come and hang
a towel on a tree
tree limb and call it good um we'll have
the bonnaroo toaster uh you know and all
the decor and facials and
we're just we're gonna have a good time
glitter everywhere
we're able to everywhere come together
the way we're used to i mean i don't
know
how much you guys want to go into that
but i mean
that that guest camping is gone brad
that's well that's not there anymore i
don't know how much you're that's not
what i heard that is
daniel's shaking his head daniel
what what do you know daniel oh i just
know the same thing that taco knows
we've been gossiping about that
i don't know nothing what do you mean
you think that
you think we're good
i'm not going on insider information i'm
seeing it with my eyes it's a yeah
okay
okay brian what what what do you see
with your eyes tell me what those eyes
see those beautiful blue eyes awesome
camping is where death camping used to
be like
based on like an older ultra vip
it's based on they sell tickets for
platinum camping i've been back there
where we exactly where we camp and
there's a big [ __ ] sign that says
platinum cramping
i don't need an insider from cbs to tell
me this
okay so you're telling me that in the
middle of the field
during october that when you draw drove
to the bonnaroo field you saw a sign
that said platinum camping next to our
this was september of last year one week
after the cancellation i went to
nashville anyway and the the
configuration is the exact same this
year from from what i can tell i haven't
seen this years with my own eyes but why
would they not do the exact same thing
they did last year when it's mapped out
that way still
i'm telling you i'm not i don't want to
be worried this is awesome i was looking
at a map last night and i couldn't find
it
it wasn't on the map it's never been on
the map though it's never been on the
map yeah it always just cuts off
by the way look at the map now brad
everybody pull it up right now behind
there there is now a platinum
no there isn't
heaven forbid you all have to come
camping
i know right this is the thing daniel
your it's first world problems at the
ultimate
i don't know brian if you look at see
this is what i knew you were going to
get to you're going to bring up the map
and the map is the same taco brought
this up a couple weeks ago that's the
same map that they used two years ago
it's the same map yes it is there's
nothing different about it
what and i'd rather talk about diesel
engines
could we go back to diesel and learn the
thing i could tell you about it
i mean honestly no i'm actually serious
about this i didn't know that that
diesel gas didn't go bad
so it kind of does and that's why
yes
goes we've been driving the robots
around the block a little bit the past
two weeks because it had to burn off
some of the diesel that gunked up it
white smoke comes out the back as if
it's announcing the next pope um after i
run it for a few miles it's just fine so
we're good to go taco is right you have
to give it a little additive like right
when the weather starts getting cold so
it doesn't get too gunky but yeah we're
good
okay all right so kai who are you
looking forward to hear seeing okay so
this year um i'm really excited because
it seems like to be like a lot of
up-and-coming artists who in a couple
years you're going to see how much
they've changed and they'll be like i
saw them and they were small so
one like some big artists that i'm
excited for are still woozy uh j cole
and just people like that there's not a
lot of big artists this year i love
steel
and he's so fantastic
we missed him at ford castle the other
weekend and i was heartbroken so this is
my my thing but some smaller artists i'm
really excited for are like flip turn
and uh the back seat lovers i love the
back seat i love the back seat lovers
because um i was one of the only guys in
the country playing that song kilby girl
uh talk about uh talk about a song that
fits that k that bonnaroo sound so well
barry oh my god it is it is almost like
the war on drugs brian you'd like it a
little bit uh but that song
could be the like if you made a sizzle
reel of bonnaroo with the sun going down
kilby girl would be the song that you
choose they absolutely destroyed at
okeechobee we were on the rail for that
and we absolutely loved it i can't wait
to see them again at roo
yeah cool and then one more video this
i'm interrupting this will be how many
for you uh how many years this is going
to be my fourth year it should be my
sixth but
got canceled yeah
all right
i'll come back go ahead go ahead with
your your picks
is southern avenue they played
riverfront nights last summer and
they're not they're really one of the
smaller bands they're playing at 1 15
like in the morning it's not in the
morning in the daytime afternoon
afternoon that's the morning
yeah
so they're their lead singer she just
has an amazing stage presence and i love
the sound lots of happy memories from
that band so it's really impressive to
see them going from riverfront nights to
playing up honoring no kidding the
riverfront night band huh uh follow it
you weren't even alive for this but you
know that's played uh front i don't know
if tara remembers that would be the
barenaked ladies
1997
yeah the greatest year of brian's life
there for that one
everybody has to start somewhere that
i'm glad to hear you say that you're
looking for you're looking forward to
seeing some of the smaller ones and and
seeing how they come
that's
kind of the whole reason this show
started was ever there yeah
hey charlotte
yeah we've become a tad jaded since then
huh
yeah i can tell
i remember seeing mumford and sons on
the small stage you know i mean that's
it's really like
one of
my favorite things is being able to walk
around to see the smaller acts and still
grow
kg elephant
playing river bend the other night and
then getting to see them at rhythm and
bruise and then at bonnaroo and then
just watching these artists it was
special well look i mean i still i still
never forget the time that we stumbled
upon this little band in a cafe called
black keys and uh the only reason i uh
went there was because i confused them
with another band that was playing and i
had a similar name and i was like i
don't know who these guys are and then
the next year they're honest they're on
the witch other than the uh this tent
and that tenth and the witch stage and
then headlining um
you know uh
on the west stage hey kitty look there's
a cat for brian to hate i like cats
how are you charlotte who are you
excited about you ready you ready to go
yes i'm very excited to see goose
it's goose i'm yeah you you and i bo
that the uh
the show last year right the the uh
virtual show that they did that's when i
first heard about him yeah that blew me
away and i think you you were the same
we all simultaneously texted each other
watching that saying who is this
and they're
this is terrific right now we're so
happy that king gizzard and goose didn't
have a conflict we feared that for
months
uh so goose and who else
goose and sac brian
yes
yeah quite excited are you so much
confident is that zach fry in the
country guy yes yes
did i miss him on the lineup barry we
haven't talked i don't think we've even
said his name out loud that's a new one
good for you
i've been preaching him for like two
months he's amazing
yeah he's got a really cool story too
exactly
yeah joe husband joe loves that loves
that how's joe
he's good he's good he's excited to
spend his father's day
uh
that's something that we actually
haven't talked much about barry every
time every year this this falls on
father's day
um and
you tell me if i'm wrong about this but
there's there's always a time
inside father's day where
i feel as though you guys get really
emotional
put all of you guys underneath oh well
that was
that was pretty strong that was pretty
strong and then you know
not only her her
talk or you know her comments about her
her wife but then jeff cuellar came up
with his kid remember and gave uh the
city or something brandy what the key to
the city so yeah that was pretty cool
but i feel like there's there is
something special oh i'm sorry the
father of the group wants to um talk
brian yes please father
i haven't
spent as an expert father of many
children what is your perspective here
on father's day obama i haven't said
father's day with my dad in almost
basically 20 years
so uh
i got to kill him
you hate your family i can't i don't
like him that much no but i mean he's
doing that
yeah to go back to joe
to go back to
joe uh you know in our camp we always
have
if if i don't have the tool
denson does or joe does
so
joe's my guy because joe literally could
build my house and has come over to save
my house when barry doesn't answer the
phone um but i'll tell you the reason
why i suggested a couple weeks ago on
bonnaroo do and don't is uh because of
joe i suggested bringing the yoga wheel
and i thought it was something that we
just don't it's too dope we just use it
nobody else is going to use it but tell
them how joe reacted to the yoga wheel
he loved it he bought like seven
no
but we have 17 yoga worlds there now
no he did he fell in love with that yoga
wheel and he bought one and he uses it
all the time and joe's excited about
some things
but uh but the yoga wheel is definitely
uh it's
it it's competing against us it is a
game changer when you're when your back
is wrecked after a day at the festival
it will change everything when you go to
sleep and when you wake up in the
morning barry
i don't know if you could do it but uh
it might help it might help yeah i
i might i want to ask kai because you've
been there you were 11
yeah when you went to your first
10.
so
you know brad and i are 16
brian's been to every one taco's been to
two
daniel you guys what are going on
six or seven a decade
last two years we start
yeah yeah okay sorry
so but we're all you know old people
what's it like having
basically grown up
attending these festivals
it's always been like such an
interesting experience because they're
not when i was that age there was really
no one my age around i would always kind
of resent my mom for that be like where
are all the kids
but it's also a really cool experience
because i get to tell all the adults
around me yeah i've been to binary more
than you so
yeah i loved playing beach volleyball in
the bacardi place i would do that for
hours on end and get so sunburned um and
then i would just go check out all the
shows like i remember seeing kylie
utches when she was on one of the this
or that dance and now she's like minion
soundtracks listen follow kai's
recommendation the girl's got an ear uh
but the other thing he said was uh
people at your age luckily someone your
age has just joined us jake from rooham
um hey jake
hello hello
i'm sorry what game did we pull you out
of that uh what is that gaming chair
you're in last time we saw you your
apartment was empty and had no furniture
now you spent all your money on this
gaming chair one that is that is a lie
there was
believe this is a furniture cream it was
a bean bag chair you were sleeping on
ham's cans kids that would mean the life
i don't know what you're talking about
hello hello
i'm doing good excited uh every day at
work it's been rough just because that's
all we're thinking about is bonnaroo so
uh i mean we're excited to get back to
the to the farm
yeah i've been listening to you guys
and obviously daniel too and and
you know
to be honest
last week i was sort of
but now after listening to all the
different shows and everything and
realizing it's gonna happen i'm pretty
excited everything feels like it's back
to the way it you know
was where
uh as far as like work like today i
picked up the laptop you know that i'm
gonna use so everything's starting to
get
back into the routine is i guess what
i'm trying to say we need it okay oh
there's no point i think
the thing that barry
the part that i start to get jealous of
is we were going through the lineup and
that's the part that didn't really
bother me the thing that got me was like
oh man
this bad lineup means i'm gonna get to
hang out with everybody
and you know kick brian in the nuts a
little bit more uh that's what i'm
that's what i missed the most
that's why i was so excited when i got a
text from tara today said hey we're
going to be there
now it feels like
nut butter is going to happen so i'm
excited
jake
we've asked everybody uh
who who you're most excited say
denzel curry is probably one of the
most hype acts uh i'm a massive porter
robinson fan so that's going to be
probably my show of the weekend i've
already seen him but
on the farm that'll probably be pretty
special um and i have recently gotten
into king giz so i am
excited for that as well
all right so he likes drugs
i got to tell you i wouldn't saw your
boy porter down at okeechobee and i was
freaking blown away i'm gonna be at that
show too it was so fun it's a six set
yeah his visuals are
insane and his newest album is awesome
i feel like he is if you're not super
into edm he's a good starting point just
because it's newer stuff is a lot more
melodic than i think
most edm is much more of like a pop
album so it's good stuff barry this is
very this is why this is why did you
brought it pack it in and retire uh and
let the let them let let the new kids
come through and start taking the show
we're glad they've taken over once
we have never once described a set as a
sixth set
no no but i'm glad i'm glad jake brought
that up and i'm glad he's on here
because those that's a that's a lane
where you ju as you just said we're not
going to uh we're probably not going to
talk about with any uh knowledge i don't
talk about anything with knowledge
first of all
well that's a good point so jake go
ahead i mean what are some of the other
shows i mean we've talked about the
other the fact that bonnaroo is sort of
dedicated you know the other to edm
um
what are what are some of the shows that
people should go see because you
obviously know more about it than we do
you guys are doing your own edm
uh
set on friday night what are some of the
other sets
people should go see this guy's pretty
good uh i would say he's sort of along
the same lines like millennium
i'm sorry say it again said the sky
okay i said this guy um
he's pretty good obviously millennium is
great um
lp geobe is super good kind of a chill
uh
idiom set
okay let me just interrupt brian
[Laughter]
it's my world
uh i'm gonna get to know lane eight
cause that's the only thing going on at
3 a.m so
that'll be fun i guess
uh and then obviously flume a big one
there um and i was also like closey it's
pretty good too
it doesn't sound as though you have a
problem with this lineup then huh i mean
it's not great uh i think there's a lot
of uh undercard acts that like parker
and i are pretty into uh if there were
some of those big acts i talked about
earlier no porter um i know for parker
he's big into the chips no chicks that
would be it'd be a pretty bad lineup i
think um
but there's enough stuff each day that
we're into i know our camp personally is
really into this lineup uh
a lot of the edm
picks like suicide boys is really huge
in our camp so
um there's enough here that'll keep me
busy i mean obviously we're in that uh
the mindset of it doesn't really matter
what the lineup is um this year more
than any is testing that a little bit
but it's still good enough i think
is nobody going to bring up herbie
hancock i mean this this i mean for sure
too you know there's i mean i love
herbie hancock that's the one that barry
keeps pointing to and again i say we
said this last week um you know i know
the ruham kids you know don't see
anything that's over the age of 26 years
old but they uh
you know you you don't have these
opportunities to see these people very
often
or ever again uh we've gone through this
enough where
we'll see a show who was the guy that
that it wasn't solomon burke but it was
an old 60s soul guy that
his last show was at bonnaroo
you know you just don't get these
no it wasn't charles bradley no i'll
look it up here in a second but um you
know you guys you don't have these
opportunities very often and the best
example is john prine so if you have an
opportunity to see one of the greatest
of all time no matter how no matter how
you feel about them just give it some
space give it some time what else are
you doing what else are you doing
drop drugs i know what do you think
about that
think about uh herbie hancock
yeah legacy acts like that are you i
mean your parents have done a great job
obviously of introducing you to music
are you i mean is that even on your
radar your mindset to know about these
guys i think that uh a big part of rue
is my mom is also the one dragging me to
some shows and um some of the shows
she's taken to me too like i've
discovered an artist i love so yeah i
like trying to see as many shows as
possible trying to find like anything
that interests me and just like focusing
on it and listening to it all the time
like i'm gonna force her to go to school
yeah
just like she made me go to what was the
one
place it was like really late at night
it was gorgeous
[Laughter]
lionel richie it was a little dicky
dicky is the one that she tricked me
that was terrible it was rough
the worst show ever
the worst show ever
a japanese brother
i foreign i forever had this theory that
if you are seeing a band where the lead
singer's got to take his shirt off at
any point in the show they really don't
have anything he took his pants off and
showed his dick uh so
if my rule goes for the
like like blown up penises like floating
flying through the air hitting people in
the head it was great we were right up
front i was like 12 years old
my mommy uh
brian's now looking at his schedule
wondering where the giant flying penises
are no i'm i'm looking at the
like you said it was a bad shot and i'm
camping here and just whenever you want
to see it just let me know
camping is what you're looking at is
right behind the wall where the comedy
tent was brian they do not and never
have never once have ever put the woods
on
the map ever they've never put where we
camp on the map at any point because it
doesn't exist in the border world so
whatever you see on the map is a created
map that doesn't they also don't put the
trash section in there
brian
there's parts of the map they just do
not include
i've seen it with my own eyes brad
okay
okay
anyway anyway jake we're gonna get back
to you he didn't get to hear that oh i
was watching i was pissed that i missed
easily i could have had it so much that
conversation
hey go ahead i'm i'm all in i'm only
doing some diesel talk i know nothing
about cars so i i have done questions
about it like for instance hang on a
second
car question
taco what's in your cabinet
you got to wait till the glow light goes
off before you taco what's in your
what's in your cabinet today
yeah what's in the cabinet
oh i don't but you wanted to do the
thing i wanted to see the thing
was this like a celebrity what's in your
fridge
nobody knows that reference
jake you guys have like what 40 people
come in five in your group 36 something
like that
yeah and i know you you guys have talked
a little bit because we've talked a
little bit but are you guys at all
i mean the numbers does it bother you
not really i mean i wasn't there in
yeah i wasn't there in 2016. they're
and he talks about how nice it was to
have a
smaller amount of people um
obviously i wouldn't want it to be so
low to where it feels dead um because i
do think you could hit a certain point
where the vibes are kind of affected
because it just feels like no one's
there and especially if they start to
like close in the farm or center ruin
anyway um
but ultimately as long as it still feels
like bonnaroo i'm not gonna supermind
and i'm not gonna care if i can get a
better spot at a headliner show
it was a little weird in 2016. i
remember we were out and about in
cineroo at like 2 a.m kind of close to
snake and jake's and it just felt empty
i forget who was playing but it was at
that time it felt like there was only
like maybe like two or three hundred
people there it's gonna be weird i've
been telling people i'm not so worried
about it being like 30k or whatever the
number is or whatever because it's going
to be
the most dedicated people so it kind of
feels like it's going 2016 was a great
year because of that like it's always a
good crowd never not great but like
there was just something in the air that
year because it was mostly a population
of the people that were hardcore into it
and i'm kind of excited about that being
a deal again this year
yeah it does it does it does seem to be
set up as though uh it's going to be the
vip of bonnaroo
you know it's like the hardcore guys
that are that are all in on it no matter
what um
and that does create you know a better
sense of community than
you know
sort of the fist fights you get at
lollapalooza that's very true
yeah all right i gotta run boys and
girls that's good everybody i mix like i
said what are you doing going to
we got the artemis mission coming up
later this fall oh of course the
artist's mission who didn't know about
that
[Music]
they're doing tests
brad the space shuttle hasn't run in 15
years
oh damn it
that's what the artemis rocket is it's
going to be the next moon rocket they're
testing it this month and we're going to
have boots on the moon again in probably
about uh four or five years
okay all right i'll see you there
but i'll see you guys later get to hang
with me
see you buddy good seeing you excited to
see you in a week hey brad what's your
what's your car question
now we're on space shuttles
what's the best threat on a tire never
know what under ideal conditions under
ideal conditions diesel fuel can be
stored between 6 and 12 months
so there's your answer good all right
there you go very good
very excited
thanks brian you're welcome you know
that's awesome the
the the amount that you contribute it
always is unparalleled
i have another question for kyle
any of your friends i'm sorry wanna go
do any of your friends want to go and
and do you have any friends that you
would want to go with you or would they
get in your way
oh
really i can't no um
there are there are a couple you don't
have to name names yeah i won't name any
names there's some people that i know
that are good
and um
we're going and i'm not excited if i run
into um and there are a couple people
that want to go that i would not want to
go and there are a couple people that do
that i want to go and it's i guess
that's just kind of how it is uh our
friend finley we're trying to get her to
go with us if you have any more passes
we would like to get one more teenager
in there
but yeah i think that like
the past couple of festivals riverbend
was like a really big one because it's
mostly teenagers not this year so much
but i really enjoy having like a friend
around to go hustle around and
see everything we can so mom's not
having to tag along with me everywhere
and she's getting to the age we've been
teaching her right you know it's like
be careful in the pit stay hydrated
we're getting to that point where she
knows the farm well enough
uh you know jake i don't know what your
age range is but if there's any cool
don't give him any ideas don't give him
any ideas
[Laughter]
he's gonna
[Laughter]
yeah
uh jake of the of the 30 or 40
how many percentage-wise have been
before are they i mean i'm particularly
interested how many are new i mean did
you guys talk
[ __ ] it up and you got a whole bunch of
new people
[Music]
vast majority of them are new um we had
a couple people who went to like fake
crew last year so they were going to
bonnaroo and then it got canceled so we
did other stuff um so they kind of got a
sense of what banner would be sort of
like because we went to a one of those
alternate routings um but yeah most are
new a lot of them are have festival
experience so they go to like electric
forest or lost lands and stuff like that
so
not completely new festival goers
so y'all
you guys are a great person to ask the
question and i know you talked about it
a little bit on your show because we did
too is why maybe the numbers are down i
mean did did
did people sort of lose the vibe did
they lose the mojo because of what
happened the last two years but it's i
mean if you've got 30 or 40 people
coming especially 60 percent that are
new
uh sounds like you guys have yeah
enough it was mostly us convincing on
the camping side because the lineup
didn't i don't think did it for a ton of
people most people who are going have
like one artist that they want to see
um
i think for the people who normally go
with this who didn't go this year it
came down to money in the lineup which i
think is both those things go together i
mean obviously we're not in a great
economy um you know with inflation and
gas prices and stuff and so if you have
less money to spend
and you can only go to one festival and
that one festival has a
mid or lower tier lineup in your opinion
you're gonna go somewhere else you'll
spend it on local shows and so i think
for i know a lot of people that's the
case they have less pto they're less
money so bonner's just not where they're
going
are most of the people you're going with
from where you get your minnesota right
and j
oh god uh parker sorry sorry parker or
jimmy yeah uh he's in iowa so uh big
fans but are you guys uh are you guys in
the same
as all the friends from the same city no
we have um from everywhere couple from
minnesota from iowa a couple from
colorado new york
um
a couple other states i think uh not
super sure okay
then when they get there because you
said you had to convince them to go do
you feel any pressure when they get
there to make their you know be the
entertainment
i mean i think because most of them have
been to festivals
there and camping festivals they'll be
ready to kind of make that fun
um
so no i don't think so i think like
because i mean i when i went with parker
for the first year i didn't know what to
expect and within like two hours i was
having an amazing time so it does not
take long once you're in bonnaroo to
start having fun especially that
wednesday night
yeah because most of the time when i
invite somebody to bonnaroo the first
job i give them is they have to run the
door for uh brian stone's campsite uh
because he you don't know how many
people are coming in and out of that
tent where did he
go i don't know i think i think
everything's special about that
bringing in when you've got somebody
who's their first year you know like
this will be 16 for me and
when i hear that some when i hear you've
got that many new folks coming i
automatically i'm like okay after this
we're going to connect i want to come
hang out with all of them
well yeah you but that's yours so like
i'm just sitting here thinking
now i'm so glad you and kai are coming
because i'll have somebody to talk to
because i'll never see brian and and
russ once we get it
but good thing that he can't hear
because he's making a shitload of racket
you know of course it's all about brian
and he's gone oh god it's probably
better that way
[Laughter]
careful we got children i'm sorry
sorry jake sorry
that was a good one
i'm so sorry
there you go uh no real quick so sorry i
didn't mean it like that a wizard staff
you take a beer and you drink it you get
another beer you stack it on top you
duct tape it up and then you drink that
beer and then you take another beer and
you stack it on top there and then you
know by the time you get six or seven in
you've got a really long wizard staff
that you're uh that you're
consuming all your power from
there you go
see kai there is much to learn i was
taking nuts
when you drink shitty beer you really
got to come up with clever ways to keep
i don't know about shitty brother
okay
speaking of [ __ ] yeah yeah we're working
on the tv
shitty brian
all right
yeah i'm back
there he is he's back jake when are you
guys getting there wednesday uh we'll
get there probably wednesday like
morning ish
russ is leaving in the morning
tomorrow morning
tomorrow morning that it doesn't open
until late next week but he's leaving
tomorrow we're heading out thursday
afternoon
all right brian what are you looking at
i don't know i got the whole week off i
can do whatever i want i'm gonna let it
just let it feel feel it out
he's really good at that by the way
whenever he's got you know well
that's it
you know i just oh sorry i suggested
eating early
and then get our camp spot ready
and talking camping
[Laughter]
text me and let me know where we're at
so we're not going to be able to for
doesn't understand what happens here um
and and jake you don't know this either
but what would normally have happened
right about now is whenever the schedule
comes out we get the whole campsite
together and uh we do sort of a planning
meeting where we go through the schedule
we find out what everybody's exactly
like this and then it always ends up the
exact same way us all just making fun of
brian
so that's essentially what you're a part
of jake you uh you get to yeah i'm
honored and then we make dad pick up the
bill
yeah i'm a big fan of that
that dad you've gotten rid of you've
gotten out of picking up the tab for the
last like four years now
you owe me
i'm getting quicker getting quicker
getting quicker
all right i'm looking forward to it i'm
excited um
what about stevie nick does that do
anything for anybody
yeah oh
yeah it's another legacy act yeah
you know sounds like an overwhelming
response
everybody's saying i'm gonna not over
schedule too much this year i'm going to
kind of take it easy you got to spin it
however you want to i can't imagine how
many axe densons sing is densen going
well speaking of
speaking of jake you you will be the
best person to answer this because you
guys are going to be out there with 30
people what are the chances
you never make it into center room oh
low what are the chances everything is
happening so so great out there that you
just never leave i mean
low because i know especially me and
parker we see quite a few shows during
the weekend but uh
every year bonner seems to be adding
more and more to essentially keep you
out of center i mean i don't know if any
of you went to where in the woods the
previous year um but that's incredible
like i could spend a good amount of my
weekend there and i intend to this year
so that plus the plaza shows and stuff
like that um you could spend a good
amount of time outside of center and
still have a really
you know fun uh weekend but yeah we'll
be in there there's there's plenty of
stuff we want to see
now barry barry have you ever looked at
barry schedule or is it is that is that
the same question of brian stone
okay oh i already know the answer
right he was gone i said brian i once we
get there i won't see you again
till next week or two weeks
we'll be camped next to each other but
i'll never see you
we'll be locked because we won't have
our campground and we won't know where
we're going
i know that paul coffin is playing out
there right
that's yeah i'm gonna go see him yeah
that's gonna be a really great show he
is
so much fun
he is
now for those who don't know i mean tara
knows all this because she ran a music
venue in chattanooga are you still are
you still doing that
no i left uh during the pandemic and uh
changed gears i'm still doing a little
show wrap work on the sides but
for the most part but you keep your
fingers
you know the hell is going on around
there oh yeah
we know what's going on hey speaking of
which the reason i have this up here and
i wanted to brag
this guy right here mike dewer and this
guy chris cobb
booked the riverbend festival which just
happened this last weekend and it was
terrific yeah and uh i wanted to give
them a shout out i don't know we've had
chris hang on the job and this this guy
right here
we've had chris on the show before but
the thing about
the thing if you don't remember that's
one of my favorite things about chris
the thing about the thing about chris
joe is that uh he also books live on the
green we have a large amount of people
live in nashville he does the live in
the green show too yeah and exit yeah
yeah yeah but i just wanted to
give them a shout out riverbend went
really really well it was a great lineup
and they did a tremendous job and those
are camp nuts okay so because we've
never done this we have never once done
this on the show
please tell the infamous that's a chick
story barry
oh i should do that so
all of those faces are on these giant
heads that brad had made for ryan
actually brian get yours and ready get
you ready and bring it in brian's is
right
yeah and so we were camped next to a
couple of girls who spent the entire
time on some sort of drug
i i don't know what
but on a saturday night they came over
and thanked us for having our lights and
all that stuff because that's how they
found their way home which we've talked
about finding landmarks and all that
and they
and they went around and they finally
realized oh all of these faces on these
giant heads are you guys yeah so that's
yeah she literally she literally looked
right
that's you that's you and then
brian was literally sitting in front of
you and she looked at this one
just just in the same house
just like that
just like that
and she said that's a chip
and we're like he's literally sitting
right in front of me
she no that's a chick
[Laughter]
it was the eyes man they were
penetrating yeah these things are almost
10 years old it was 2013 i believe yeah
it was uh if i remember
yeah it was so funny though because he's
like i'm sitting right here no
yeah
unbelievable
by the way
all designed by the man who also
designed the interlude music of this
podcast mr nick turner who is also on
that big board of yours back there right
there in the middle right next to me
before she left she pointed at mike and
said that's a good looking man if you
want to come see me later i think that
kept mike alive in three years i think
that kept him going for a minute it was
a
it was a pretty good night pretty funny
but that's a chick yeah all right well i
i hate that i miss you all uh i already
i hope you're already planning
by the way barry yet again this is my
second city that i have lived in since
uh i've left you and brian will have
seen me more times than you have
i've told you the map that i have
hanging up on the wall of all the places
that i've never visited
it just keeps getting bigger and better
brian's coming up taco i'm sure will be
coming up soon enough you know because
he's a big city kid um
yeah i know going to new york uh i hope
tara comes and in august
and then i hope that uh you know jake
can get his parents to let him out of
the house sometime um
i'm gonna sign my permission
i want to ask kai i want to give kai a
chance what did we not ask you what did
we not ask me um
cool kid
tara you've done great thank you y'all
done great helping me out
yeah it's been a great experience
getting to sit and guest with you guys
and look down on all the ga people
that's not what we do
tell them that
created a monster he said we might be
uh i've been in there once
[Laughter]
things
this is making jake sick to his stomach
[Laughter]
i'm jealous i think i think
group camping which you got is going to
be awesome
yeah we're hoping so
i'm gonna
yeah i'm guessing so jake what do you
have to say
i'm excited to see uh
let's see here three-fourths of you uh
you're excluding the one that you're
excluding is of course brian
oh yeah
yeah definitely
uh but yeah it's gonna be a good year i
mean
smaller attendance isn't a big deal it's
gonna be bonnaroo either way and so uh
we're excited to have give group uh
camping a shot and
yeah just be back
we can't do another cancellation or a
postponement wait it's gonna
say am i am i an idiot have you guys not
done group before
no oh okay
no we just said ga no like last year we
did and we got like 15 people um
who are gonna go and they're canceled
and then the year before that is like 10
or 12 and then it was mean parker in
2018.
super fast explain the group camping
because i actually don't know exactly
how it's like there's a podcast
dedicated to this brian that you could
have listened to i don't know one two
three of them four of them i don't know
how they are now
you have friends his head collapses to
the ground
the cat the cat knocked the head over
that's awesome
i honestly don't know how proof camping
works i mean
it's just our first year about how the
name works it's literally group
camping
it's pretty self-explanatory i mean you
basically have to have i think 24 or 25
people and then once you hit that
threshold you all sign up
on the website you pay like 50 bucks i
think it was per person and then bonus
gives you like
essentially a plot of land kind of in
group camping and so instead of having
to drive in and go through security and
then just be brought to a random area
they have it ready for you so you can
show up at any point and they'll take
you
it's really beneficial brian for like if
you come by yourself
you know you don't know anybody champion
it's a bunch of group of people together
i didn't know exactly how i was going
bundle
they bundle you together you're
guaranteed so you could come in on
thursday friday whatever and you're and
you gotta have 25 or whatever more
sorry to ruin the show jesus christ brad
i wish
speaking of why we while we're all here
while we're all here we should all
congratulate brian oh yeah
congratulations yeah
yeah good good where'd he go brian good
job yeah
where to bring where to bring that
trophy to atlanta
what was your what was your era in those
two games you pitched
so last episode brian is supposed to be
a part of it but no no he chose hardware
over
coming to hang out with us no he needed
to go see a trophy that he could have
very well just driven down 90 miles and
see at the ballpark no he didn't see it
i'm not going to apologize for this i'm
not going to apologize for this
was it a night ball
you know that riverbend it was the next
day nightfall
oh they had all friday
well taco how many pbrs is that how many
did we get through today
that's chuck change
it's working numbers good start you
heard the same good start it's not a
good win
yeah yeah it's not a good wizard
all right oh it's so funny
can't wait to see y'all
thank you
all right thank you
glad you're joining me i'm so glad to
see you guys i'm so i missed your faces
tell joe i said hello and um
he might need to come over and help fix
the fence here soon uh
taco nice shirt
i appreciate that
yeah uh jake i uh i appreciate the uh
the trumpet mustache that you're uh
going for
i went for it
it's like you've just been playing the
trumpet too hard you know this thing's
real facial there and then brian stone
who you know has gained a few pounds
all right
love you brian that's a check very good
guys i miss you i'll miss you so much
have fun see you guys in a week
[Music]
[Music]
consequence podcast network